(Frau) Wunderbar. Ja, dann
verteile ich jetzt mal die Masken.
Ihr dürft einfach eine nehmen.
Probiert sie doch schon mal an!
Augenmasken
für das bevorstehende Blind Date,
und das im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes,
denn die Männer und Frauen,
die sich hier gleich begegnen werden,
sollen sich nicht sehen,
sondern sich durch riechen,
tasten und spüren näherkommen.
Und, passt sie?
- Tipptopp.
Gut, wunderbar.
Ja, dann sind wir bereit.
Dann warten wir jetzt noch
auf die Frauen, und dann geht's los.
Willkommen zu "Reporter spezial".
In dieser Sendung
geht es um die Lebensmitte
und um die Frage,
die sich irgendwann stellt:
Kommt da noch etwas?
Oder kommt da noch jemand?
Die Phase zwischen 40 und 55
ist für viele Beziehungen
ein Prüfstein.
Es gibt solche -
die treffen wir in dieser Sendung -,
die sich durchkämpfen
und einfach weitermachen,
und es gibt andere,
die plötzlich offen für Neues sind.
Und die treffe ich hier drin.
Die Männer sind hier schon bereit,
die Frauen
sind noch im anderen Zimmer.
Beim Sensual Speeddating
wollen sich Männer und Frauen
mit allen Sinnen kennenlernen.
(Frau) Wir sind jetzt bereit.
Gleich geht's los. Seid ihr nervös?
- Ja, schon ein wenig.
Eine der Teilnehmerinnen ist Petra.
Frisch verliebt, ist sie Bekannt-
schaften dennoch nicht abgeneigt.
Yeah, ready.
- Ready.
Monica ist sogar in Begleitung
ihres Mannes zum Daten gekommen.
Bei jeder Begegnung fragen wir:
"Hat dir diese Person gefallen?"
"Hat dir diese Begegnung gefallen?"
Dann hebst du den Arm.
Wenn es dir nicht gefallen hat,
hebst du ihn nicht.
Und wenn es dir super gefallen hat
und du dich wirklich
an diese Person erinnern willst -
mach das also nicht zu viel -,
kannst du einen Super-Like machen,
indem du beide Arme hebst.
Das ist der Gedanke.
Also nicht zu oft einsetzen,
weil du es sonst
am Ende nicht nachvollziehen kannst.
Ich bin auch nervös,
obwohl ich nichts tun muss.
Es ist eine ...
Für mich wäre es
eine seltsame Vorstellung,
dass mich Menschen anfassen,
die ich nicht kenne.
Wie ist das für dich?
- Gerade das finde ich reizvoll.
Über diesen Sinn
jemand völlig Fremdes kennenzulernen
und einfach zu spüren,
wie sich das anfühlt.
Wo kann man das schon? Das kann man
hier, und das finde ich reizvoll.
Warum geht ihr
nicht einfach auf Tinder
und schaut, wer mit euch matcht?
(Frau) Dort bin ich auch.
Ganz ehrlich, weil ich mich noch nie
mit anderen Dating-Sachen
beschäftigt habe.
Ich habe von Sensual Speeddating
gehört und gedacht:
"Das ist mein Ding.
Das finde ich cool."
Alles andere wollte ich
lieber nicht ausprobieren.
Da habe ich zu viel Stress,
gerade mit der Optik.
Zu sagen: "Ich guck mir Leute an,
und dann wische ich die weg
oder werde weggewischt."
Auf keinen Fall.
- Ich spiele die volle Klaviatur.
Also, ich bin auf Tinder,
ich bin in einer Partnerschaft
und ich bin einfach gespannt,
welche neuen Wege es gibt,
Menschen zu erfahren und zu treffen.
Darum geht es mir im Grunde: Ich
connecte einfach gerne mit Menschen.
Das ist einfach eine neue Ebene, ja.
Dann könnt ihr jetzt die Masken
anziehen, und dann gehen wir rüber.
(Leiterin) Ist das okay?
- Ja.
Okay, dann könnt ihr euch
mit den Masken anfreunden.
(Leiterin) Yeah.
Achtung,
hier geht es über Yoga-Matten.
Genau.
Dir gegenüber ist jetzt ein Mensch.
Du kannst noch einen Moment warten.
Dann darfst du langsam
die Hände vor dir ausstrecken
und in die Verbindung reingehen.
Miteinander ankommen, erst mal.
Erst mal einfach die Hände halten
und reinspüren,
wie sich das anfühlt, diese Hände.
Setz deinen Tastsinn
und deinen Geruchssinn ein,
um herauszufinden,
wie dir diese Frau gefällt!
Wen kann ich gut riechen?
Wer fühlt sich richtig gut an?
Mit wem matcht es?
Das Gegenüber
mit allen Sinnen zu erfahren,
darum geht es
beim Sensual Speeddating.
Es gibt Anlässe für Singles,
aber auch für Paare.
Für Hetero-, Homo- oder Bisexuelle,
für monogam oder polyamor Lebende,
wie die Teilnehmenden
an diesem Event hier.
Petra, die zweifache Mutter,
führt Liebesbeziehungen
mit mehreren Männern gleichzeitig.
* Fliessende fernöstliche Musik *
Einer von Petras Partnern ist Armin.
Wie viele Partner
hast du neben Armin noch?
Ein fester Partner,
das sehen wir nachher noch,
ist Bernhard.
Bernhard und noch zwei weitere,
die ich namentlich
nicht nennen möchte.
Und was sind die beiden,
wenn Bernhard und Armin
feste Partner sind?
Sie sind mehr wie Eckpfeiler,
die mir nicht die gleiche
Tiefe geben wie Bernhard und Armin,
sondern einfach die Leichtigkeit,
auch ein wenig ...
Ja, auch eine Offenheit.
Wie viele seid ihr jetzt im System?
Zeitmässig?
- Nein, wie viele Personen.
Wie viele Personen
beinhaltet eure Beziehung?
Äh, da müsste ich nachzählen.
Drei und drei, nicht? Also sechs.
- Drei und drei, ja. Etwa sechs.
(Beide)
Wobei manche wieder andere haben.
Eben, das ist
wie ein Schneeballsystem.
Ja, ich nenne das ...
- ... eine Wolke.
Ja, eine Wolke.
Ich nenne es Polyküle.
Das sind einfach
verschiedene Verbindungen.
Petra ist die Partnerin, mit der ich
die meiste Zeit verbringe -
erste Priorität, momentan.
Die anderen sehe ich seltener,
weil ich einfach nicht
die Zeit habe,
alle gleichmässig zu sehen.
* Ruhige, friedliche Musik *
"Wie du deine Polyamorie
leben kannst,
auch wenn du noch
in einer monogamen Beziehung lebst."
Das ist so der Haupttitel.
- Ja.
Es geht wirklich um Polyamorie.
"Wie wir in sieben Schritten
unsere Beziehungen
in Achtsamkeit geöffnet haben."
Das kann man schon ...
Die sieben Schritte sind ja drin.
Sind sie drin? Das weiss ich
nicht mehr. Ich muss nachschauen.
Doch, da. Siehst du? Wir müssen
v.a. die Bilder noch ändern.
Das ist klar. Wir müssen erst
ein paar Polyamor-Bilder auftreiben.
Nein, ich würde direkt von uns ...
Das hat viel mehr Kraft, weisst du?
- Genau.
Petra und Armin bei der Gestaltung
ihrer neuen Homepage.
Sie bieten Coachings für Menschen an,
die ihre Beziehung öffnen
und neu polyamor leben wollen.
Wann hast du gespürt,
dass Poly für dich
das richtige Beziehungsmodell ist?
Ich habe das schon ...
Ich wusste damals nur noch nicht,
dass es das war.
Ich lebte es einfach.
Ich konnte es
einfach nicht betiteln,
weil ich nicht wusste,
dass es einen Namen dafür gibt.
Damit fing ich schon früh an,
also mit 20, 21,
bis ich in die Ehe eintrat
und mich
in eine monogame Situation begab.
Dann merkte ich: "Das geht nicht.
Ich lebe nicht mein Leben."
Das kam dann plötzlich
von ganz tief unten.
Da merkte ich:
"Ich muss das ändern."
Da gab es nichts anderes,
auch wenn ich damit
sicher viele verletzt habe.
Das tut mir sehr, sehr leid.
- Also die Familie?
Den Ex-Partner, die Kinder?
- Ja, genau.
Das meinst du damit.
- Ja, ja.
Dann gingst du den anderen Weg.
Was hiess das?
Ja, also ...
Es war eine ziemliche
Selbstwert-Aufpolierung.
Ich zog mit den Kindern aus
und musste wirklich an mir arbeiten.
Für den Partner
wäre es nicht infrage gekommen,
anders zu leben?
Nein. Wir haben es probiert.
Wir haben das ausgetüftelt.
Wir haben auch Therapien usw.
probiert, aber es ging nicht.
Er will seinen Weg in der
Monogamie gehen, das ist ganz klar,
auch mit der neuen Partnerin.
Die beiden
haben eine sehr schöne Beziehung.
Und ich gehe jetzt meinen Weg, ja.
Nach 12-jähriger Ehe hat sich Petra
von ihrem Mann getrennt
und lebt nun offiziell polyamor.
Mit Armin
ist sie seit gut einem Jahr zusammen.
Ihr habt schon auch
eine Form von Verbindlichkeit.
Genau.
- Gibt's Regeln zwischen euch?
Was für Regeln haben wir?
Die wirklich wichtige Regel
haben wir in der Sexualität,
dass wir sicher
Safer Sex praktizieren.
Mit anderen.
- Mit anderen.
Und Offenheit.
- Kommunikation, mitteilen.
Genau. Das ist eine "Regel",
aber die haben wir nie aufgestellt.
Das ist einfach klar.
- Das ist die gemeinsame Basis.
Polyamorie kann nur mit Vertrauen
und Wissensaustausch funktionieren,
denn erst,
wenn ich alles über sie weiss,
kann ich für mich
selbst entscheiden, ob ich das will.
Wenn sie mir
Sachen vorenthalten würde,
könnte ich mich nicht entscheiden,
weil ich das gar nicht wüsste.
Wenn sie jemanden kennenlernen würde,
müsste sie erst dich anrufen?
Nein.
- Um zu fragen: "Darf ich ..."
Morgens um 3 Uhr rufe ich an.
Nein, das geht auch im Nachhinein,
aber einfach nicht ...
Nicht nichts sagen.
- ... ein halbes Jahr später sagen:
"Ich habe ein halbes Jahr lang eine
Beziehung mit jemandem geführt."
Das wäre komisch.
- Ja, das merkst du ja auch.
Aber wenn wir uns
das nächste Mal sehen, sagt sie:
"Ich habe einen getroffen."
Ich mache das meist
gleich am Morgen danach.
* Idyllische Musik *
Ich erlebe einfach,
dass im Moment wahnsinnig viele
Sehnsüchte und Träume
auf die Polyamorie und auf
die offene Beziehung gelegt werden.
Das Schwierige am Ganzen, denke ich,
ist wirklich der Aufwand,
wenn man das vielleicht
unter diesem Wort subsummieren kann.
Man muss noch mehr leisten.
Man ist auch mit neuen Erlebnissen
und Herausforderungen konfrontiert,
die man in einer monogamen Beziehung
nicht kennt.
Es geht auch um die Verteilung
von Zeit, von Paarereignissen.
Das kann etwas Banales sein:
"Mit wem
verbringe ich meinen Geburtstag?"
Wer hat, wenn's hart auf hart kommt,
ein Vetorecht oder das Vorrecht?
Das klingt jetzt alles
unromantisch und logistisch,
aber polyamore Paare
kennen diese Diskussionen.
Petra und Armin
sind mit Bernhard verabredet,
Petras zweitem festen Partner.
(Petra) Hallo.
Petra und Bernhard haben sich
erst kürzlich in einander verliebt.
Was ist jetzt wichtig,
wenn man zu dritt aufeinandertrifft?
Dass die Verbindung stattfindet,
also nicht nur
zwischen Bernhard und mir -
das ist natürlich
eine sehr enge Verbindung -,
sondern auch
zwischen Armin und Bernhard.
Dass bei uns dreien wirklich wieder
dieses Zusammenkitten stattfindet.
Damit sich
auch niemand übergangen fühlt.
Erst ein Mann, jetzt zwei.
Wie ist das gerade so dazwischen?
Du stehst ja auch dazwischen.
- In der Mitte, genau.
Ich sehe mich nicht ... Ich sehe
mich eher als Verbindungsglied.
Das verbindet alles miteinander.
Unser Slogan ist: "Wem's nicht
gefällt, der muss etwas sagen."
Wenn irgendwas aufkommt,
einfach darüber reden.
Dann können wir auch zusammen sein.
Sonst ist ... Sonst geht es nicht.
Sonst funktioniert
kein Zusammenleben.
Ich war dieses Wochenende tanzen
und frage mich gerade,
ob ich daher voller Energie bin
oder weil ich euch jetzt sehe.
Ach, komm, du bist doch so verliebt.
Nein, ich spüre die Leichtigkeit,
die zwischen uns herrscht.
Kannst du hier sitzen?
- Ja.
Wir sind ganz eng zusammen.
Und du bist wieder in der Mitte.
Was gibt dir Armin, was Bernhard
dir nicht gibt und umgekehrt?
Das ist eine gute Frage, wirklich.
Du hast mal gesagt,
ich rede weniger als Bernhard.
Ist das jetzt gut oder nicht?
Nein, einfach als Unterschied.
- Als Unterschied, ja.
Bernhard gibt mir diese
Lebendigkeit, Lockerheit, dieses ...
Wir sind noch voll
in der Verliebtheit.
Und bei dir es natürlich schon ...
Auch das mit dem Business.
Wir sind auf einem Pferd.
Wir halten zusammen den Gaul.
Oh, die Schmetterlinge
sind also schon weg?
Nicht ganz.
- Nein, nein, das nicht.
Nein, gar nicht.
Wir haben schon auch
diesen wunderschönen, erotischen
und sinnlichen Austausch
und eine wunderbare Sexualität. Ja.
Die ich ...
Ja, die ich jedem wünsche.
Als es bei uns funkte,
als wir uns damals küssten,
wussten wir ja nicht,
was daraus entstehen würde.
Es ist dann auch
so ein achtsames Weitergehen.
Man lässt einfach den Weg entstehen.
Ich beziehe Andrea ein
und schaue mit dir noch.
Einfach, dass es entstehen darf.
Alles.
- Alles? Komm!
Gib her!
Wie ist es für dich, Armin,
dass Bernhard dazugekommen ist?
Das ist nicht dazugekommen,
sondern es gehört zu Petra.
Es gab vorher schon Männer.
Ich wusste ja,
dass du nicht allein bist.
Sie sind z.T. auch wieder gegangen.
Oder sie wurden gegangen.
- Oder sie wurden gegangen.
Es hat einfach nicht mehr gestimmt.
- Ja, es muss wirklich stimmen.
(Leiterin) Ja, dann könnt ihr euch
jetzt wieder an den Händen fassen -
eine Hand oder zwei.
Zurück beim Sensual Speedating.
Ein stiller Abschied für den Moment.
Ihr werdet euch in den
nächsten Runden ja wieder begegnen.
Und dann könnt ihr abstimmen
und uns ein Zeichen geben,
ob euch die Begegnung gefallen hat.
Noch als kleine Erinnerung:
Super-Likes machen in dieser Runde
meist am meisten Sinn,
weil da
so viele Sachen zusammenkommen.
Per Handzeichen
geben die Teilnehmenden an,
wie ihnen die Begegnung gefallen hat.
Die Organisatorinnen halten
die Ergebnisse nach jeder Runde fest.
Aufgrund ihrer eigenen,
enttäuschenden Erfahrungen
mit den gängigen
Datingplattformen und -events
wollen die beiden Frauen
mit ihren Anlässen
ein Gegenprogramm
zu Tinder und Co. bieten.
Gut, liebe Männer, dann dürft ihr
euch wieder an den Händen fassen
und rotiert eine Matte nach rechts.
Wie ist es bei euch?
Was für Beziehungen lebt ihr?
Ich lebe jetzt
eine monogame Beziehung.
Falls wir mal das Bedürfnis
nach anderen Menschen haben.
Müssen wir darüber reden.
Wir reden dann, wenn es aktuell ist.
Wir wollen einfach
ehrlich zueinander sein. Ja.
Und ihr habt
sozusagen diese Offenheit,
dass es angesprochen werden darf,
wenn andere Bedürfnisse aufkommen.
Ja, eben.
- Das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Ich glaube, das ist für viele
eine grosse Hemmschwelle,
wenn sie merken,
dass sie Lust auf andere hätten,
aber Angst haben, das anzusprechen,
weil der andere
vielleicht davonläuft.
Ich glaube,
das ist die schönste Voraussetzung,
wenn diese Offenheit vorhanden ist.
Du lebst eine offene Beziehung?
- Ja, genau.
Ich habe auch monogam angefangen.
Mein Freund ging dann ein Jahr weg -
auf Reisen und studieren.
Dann war es einfacher, zu sagen:
"Wenn du sowieso weg bist,
probieren wir das mal."
Als er zurückkam, merkten wir aber,
dass es stimmig war,
das weiter so zu leben.
Wir wollten die gewonnene Freiheit
nicht einfach wieder aufgeben.
Wir schauen einfach,
wie's weitergeht.
Lass all
die letzten Begegnungen los ...
... und mach dich wieder frisch für
die neue Person, die vor dir steht,
mit der du jetzt das erste Mal
in Kontakt treten wirst.
Eine offene Beziehung leben
oder Polyamorie -
vielleicht ist der Mensch wirklich
nicht für die Monogamie gemacht.
Das könnte die Antwort
auf unsere hohe Scheidungsrate sein.
Auf dieses Thema
kommen wir auf jeden Fall zurück,
aber erst wollen wir wissen,
wie es ist,
wenn eine langjährige Beziehung
auseinanderfällt
und man in der Mitte des Lebens
plötzlich allein dasteht.
* Gesplitterte,
stakkatoartige Musik *
Das waren 30 Jahre.
Welche Bedeutung
hat dieser Ring jetzt für Sie?
Im Moment sind es
einfach noch die Erinnerungen.
Erinnerungen an gute Zeiten ...
... schlechte Zeiten.
Es war ein Lebensabschnitt.
Tja, aber jetzt ist es vorbei.
Aber er ist noch da.
- Im Moment ist er noch da.
Das braucht wahrscheinlich
noch einen Schritt mehr,
aber ich glaube,
ich bin langsam so weit. Ja. Ja.
Und wo kommt er dann hin?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Entweder
ist er gar nicht mehr da ...
Das wäre wahrscheinlich das Beste.
Das muss man tun, sonst kann ich
persönlich nicht abschliessen.
Ich habe das
wie eine Beerdigung gesehen.
Das ist wie wenn jemand stirbt:
Es ist fertig,
definitiv abgeschlossen.
Die Scheidung?
- Ja.
Für mich war es ein Gefühl,
wie wenn ich einen Teil von mir
losgelassen hätte.
Von einer ...
... ja, Lebensgeschichte.
Ich glaube, das ist so
ein richtiger Cocktail von Gefühlen,
auch Wut ...
... Versagen.
Auch zu erkennen, dass man den
Menschen so ganz anders gesehen hat
und wie es jetzt ist.
Drei Menschen,
drei unabhängige Scheidungsfälle,
die nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Rolf wurde nach 30-jähriger Beziehung
von seiner Frau verlassen.
Auch die erwachsenen Söhne
sind unterdessen ausgezogen.
Eine Zäsur. Mitten im Leben fühlt
sich Rolf zurückgelassen, allein.
Sie haben die Fotoalben
also auf dem Dachboden?
Die habe ich weggeräumt, richtig.
- Ja.
Also
aus der näheren Umgebung weggeräumt.
Ja.
Haben Sie das in der Zwischenzeit
je wieder angeschaut?
Ja, das habe ich schon
mehrfach angesehen, ja, ganz klar.
Ja.
- Ja.
Aber es ist klar, auch das
löst wieder Traurigkeit aus.
Aber es zeigt irgendwo auch
die Unbeschwertheit von früher.
Das ist, was wahrscheinlich
ein wenig verloren gegangen ist.
Ja. Das haben wahrscheinlich
viele andere auch durchgemacht.
* Hochzeitsmarsch: "Treulich geführt"
von Richard Wagner *
Doris fällt beim Schauen
ihres Hochzeitsvideos auf,
wie unbekümmert, glücklich,
ja fast schon naiv sie
als junge Frau ins Eheleben
gegangen ist - voller Hoffnung.
Das war wirklich
eine Liebeshochzeit,
aber das Leben verändert einen.
Die Liebe verändert sich.
Wie hat sich Ihre Liebe
denn verändert?
Es ist sicher mehr Alltag geworden.
Es ist sicher ...
... als ob man
ein Ziel erreicht hätte.
Die Hochzeit ist vorbei, und ...
... wo kommen
die neuen Ziele jetzt her?
Dann
hat man irgendwann Familie und ...
... da hat einem auch keiner
vorher gesagt,
was für eine Herausforderung das ist
und was für ein Spagat es ist,
alle Bedürfnisse
unter einen Hut zu bringen.
Ich habe auch x-mal
darüber nachgedacht,
was ich falsch gemacht habe,
was ich dazu beigetragen habe,
dass es nicht geklappt hat,
aber man ist so im Alltagstrott.
Man kommt von der Arbeit nach Hause,
ist müde,
dann haben die Kinder
wieder ein Anliegen,
und am Ende bleibt die Partnerschaft
auf der Strecke.
Man müsste ...
... ich weiss nicht.
Wenn man das Rad
zurückdrehen könnte,
müsste man Zeitfenster einbauen und
sagen: "So, jetzt sind wir wichtig."
Aber ... im Nachhinein
ist immer alles einfacher.
Schauen wir mal,
ob wir eine gute Glut haben!
Fast jede zweite Ehe wird geschieden.
Die durchschnittliche Ehedauer
liegt bei 15 Jahren.
Beziehungskiller Nummer 1, das zeigen
Studien, ist der Alltagsstress.
Die Musse für gemeinsame Augenblicke
bleibt in Langzeitbeziehungen
häufig auf der Strecke.
Es wird zu wenig gute Zeit
miteinander verbracht.
Oder vielleicht ist die Zeit,
die man miteinander verbringt,
überhaupt nicht mehr inspirierend.
Ich meine, Netflix und
Serien-Binge-Watching in Ehren,
aber wenn das alles ist,
was man als Paar noch macht ...
Das kann man genauso gut allein
oder mit einem Freund machen.
Man verpasst dabei einfach:
"Ich habe mich verändert."
"Vielleicht hat sich mein Gegenüber
ja auch verändert."
"Aber wenn ich zuhöre,
gehe ich das Risiko ein,
zu hören, dass er oder sie
nicht mehr mit mir zufrieden ist."
"Dann müsste ich vielleicht
etwas unternehmen."
Also bleibt man lieber still
und ist wieder bei
der Bequemlichkeit des Bekannten.
Auch Tobias hat sich vor Kurzem
von seiner Frau scheiden lassen,
was ihm schwergefallen ist -
gerade auch der beiden Kinder wegen,
auch wenn diese
bereits Teenager sind.
Ja, man macht sich
natürlich schon selbst Vorwürfe,
weil sie es gewohnt sind ...
... dass Papi
immer im gleichen Haus lebt ...
... und man nur rufen muss.
Ja, das ist natürlich schon anders.
25 Jahre waren Tobias
und seine Ex-Frau ein Paar.
Schöne Zeiten, wie er sagt.
Doch gegen Ende schlich sich
immer stärker der Wunsch ein,
im Leben noch einmal neu anzufangen.
Haben Sie ab diesem Punkt
Ihre Frau nicht mehr geliebt?
Nein, das nicht,
aber einfach auf eine andere Art.
Ich schätze sie nach wie vor
als gute Freundin und Partnerin
und Mutter
unserer gemeinsamen Kinder.
Das ist etwas, das für mich selbst
nach wie vor wichtig ist. Ja.
Aber die romantische Liebe
war es nicht mehr.
Nein.
- War das der Grund?
Ja.
* Leichte Xylofonmusik *
Bei der Beziehung
in der Lebensmitte,
die nach einigen Jahren
auseinandergeht,
kommt es fast nie vor,
dass die Paare nicht auch sagen:
"Der Zustand der Sexualität hat bei
uns nicht auch eine Rolle gespielt."
Uns muss auch bewusst sein, dass
in Beziehungen Kräfte wirken ...
Z.B. die ganze Suche nach Vertraut-
heit, Entspannung, Komfort, Nähe -
das sind
Gegenspieler der Sexualität.
Aber die Leidenschaft,
die viele ab einem gewissen Punkt
in der Sexualität vermissen ...
Was wir auf der einen Seite
in einer Beziehung suchen,
nämlich beste Freunde zu sein,
Vertraute sein,
füreinander da zu sein - eigentlich
sehr schöne Beziehungswerte -,
sind nicht unbedingt wahnsinnig
attraktive, feurige Sachen,
wenn es um den nächsten
heissen Sexualpartner geht.
Wir tragen da z.T.
zu unserem eigenen Unglück bei.
Es ist nicht nur
die böse Abnützung,
sondern halt auch
eine Wohligkeit und Bequemlichkeit,
die wir vielleicht
manchmal übertreiben
oder eben auch nicht ausgleichen.
Zur Abnützung gesellen sich
in Langzeitbeziehungen
häufig Streitereien und Konflikte -
so auch bei Doris.
Trotzdem haderte sie
mit der Entscheidung,
sich von ihrem Mann zu trennen.
Aus schlechtem Gewissen,
den drei Töchtern
die vertraute Umgebung wegzunehmen.
Es gibt viele Frauen in meinem
Alter, die das nicht gemacht haben.
Ich glaube ...
... viele hätten es vielleicht,
wenn sie ganz ehrlich zu sich wären,
auch gerne gemacht,
weil sie in einer Beziehung leben,
die absolut nicht konstruktiv ist,
die einfach Gewohnheit ist oder man
sich gar nichts mehr zu sagen hat.
Aber wo es auch eine grosse
Abhängigkeit vom Partner gibt.
Deshalb traut man sich auch nicht,
weil man die Angst hat,
wie es danach weitergeht.
Trotz anfänglicher Trauer
sei die Scheidung für die gesamte
Familie eine Erleichterung gewesen.
Aufatmen.
Der Druck, ausgelöst durch
die permanente Missstimmung, sei weg.
Dennoch hoffen die Mädchen, Mama und
Papa würden wieder zusammenkommen.
Sie waren sehr traurig.
An dem Tag, als es wirklich so weit
war, haben wir alle fünf geheult.
Wie sagt man es den Kindern?
Ich habe es ihnen gar nicht gesagt.
Meine Ex-Frau
hat das kommuniziert und ...
Ja.
Es ist sehr schwierig,
dies zu kommunizieren.
Ja ...
Nein, das konnte ich nicht.
Weshalb nicht?
Jetzt sind wir wieder
beim Thema Schamgefühle.
Ja.
Man steht als nicht
gleich guter Vater da, denke ich.
Das ist Lukas' Zimmer -
unschwer zu sehen
aufgrund der Fussballtrikots.
Er ist begeisterter Fussballer.
Sind die Jungs überhaupt noch hier?
Nein, die Jungs
übernachten nicht mehr oft hier.
Nur sehr selten,
aber das Zimmer steht noch bereit.
Aber dieses grosse Haus
wirkt jetzt etwas leer.
Ganz am Anfang musste ich
von einem Ort zum nächsten rennen,
weil ich abends
nicht hier alleine sein konnte.
In meinem Bekanntenkreis
hatte ich ein, zwei Personen,
die ich anrief und fragte,
ob ich bei ihnen vorbeischauen könne
oder sie bei mir -
es ging nicht alleine.
Es riecht wunderbar.
Für Rolf eine wichtige Stütze:
seine Nachbarin.
Sie und ihr Mann
sind Rolf stets zur Seite gestanden.
Danke!
- Anstossen. Prost!
Das ist immer gut. Nicht?
Was brauchten Sie in diesem Moment?
Dass jemand da ist. Vielleicht
kannst du dich daran erinnern.
Ich rief dich an und fragte:
"Doris, kannst du vorbeikommen?"
"Kann ich dich in den Arm nehmen?"
- Stimmt.
Das brauchte ich.
Ich wusste immer, wie dringlich es
sein muss, damit ich zu dir komme.
In dieser Situation ...
Wir hatten wirklich Angst um dich.
Wollen Sie noch einmal eine
Beziehung, eine Partnerin haben?
Ich bin fest davon überzeugt,
dass das wieder möglich ist
und auch, dass man nicht
geschaffen ist, um alleine zu sein.
Es ist sicher ein Lebensziel,
nicht alleine zu bleiben und ...
... ja ...
... dass man in Zweisamkeit
leben und damit alt werden kann.
Diesen Traum gibt es noch?
- Ja, den gibt es auf jeden Fall.
* Grillenzirpen *
Krisen, Verletzungen, und der Wunsch
nach einem Neuanfang -
all das hat auch das Paar erlebt,
das ich jetzt besuche.
Aber während sich andere getrennt
haben, sind sie noch zusammen.
Ist das Liebe oder Bequemlichkeit?
Finden wir es heraus!
* Horn *
Hallo, Mona! Katharina.
- Mona, freut mich.
Kaspar.
- Kaspar, freut mich.
Ich komme einfach herein.
- Vielen Dank.
Katharina und Kaspar,
Psychotherapeutin und Musiker.
Sie verliebten sich als Teenager.
Es folgten: Hochzeit und drei Kinder.
Mittlerweile
sind die beiden 30 Jahre ein Paar.
Katharina und Kaspar, genau vor 30
Jahren hattet ihr euer erstes Date.
Katharina, war es eine Leistung,
mit Kaspar
ein halbes Leben zu verbringen?
Es ist einfach ein Geschenk,
ich bin v.a. dankbar.
Wenn ich
an unsere Anfangszeit denke,
gab es immer eine Faszination
für ihn ... also für dich.
Und auch: "Was löst der in mir aus?"
- Ja.
Ich hatte das Gefühl: "Es ist schon
krass, was der in mir auslöst."
Ich habe es
gar nicht richtig verstanden.
Habt ihr diese Faszination
30 Jahre später noch füreinander?
Ich finde das eine gute Frage.
Ich habe auch darüber nachgedacht.
Für mich ist es noch genau gleich.
Du hast es super gesagt.
Oft heisst es, dass Pärchen perfekt
zusammenpassen, alles ist gleich ...
Bei uns ist das überhaupt nicht so -
also ein Teil.
Diese Faszination
kann ich nur unterschreiben.
Katharina kommt eigentlich
aus einer so anderen Welt.
Für mich ist das Gefühl dasselbe
wie damals als ich 17 war.
Mich motiviert das auch,
das ist extrem frisch.
Das ist schon immer noch da.
Das finde ich auf jeden Fall.
Und doch gab es bei euch den Moment,
als ihr einander "betrogen" habt.
Es gab Seitensprünge.
Weshalb?
Tja ... ich weiss ... ja ...
Da ist eine gute Frage.
Im Nachhinein
ist man immer schlauer.
Also, sag mal:
Wie schlau sind wir jetzt?
Sind wir jetzt schlauer?
Ich glaube nicht.
Vielleicht.
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich glaube,
wir haben uns selbst gesucht
und wollten uns selbst
sozusagen ausloten,
unsere Grenzen kennenlernen.
Wir mussten uns von jung
zu mitteljung
zu älter, mittelalt, entwickeln.
Das braucht viele Umbrüche.
Und in dieser Entwicklung mussten
wir uns teilweise neu erfinden.
Das hat solche Seitensprünge
wahrscheinlich auch mitverursacht.
So würde ich das
im Nachhinein sagen.
Wie bist du damit umgegangen,
als Kaspar ... hat er es dir gesagt?
Als ich das Gefühl hatte,
du seist dir nicht mehr sicher,
was du wolltest ...
In diesem Moment merkte ich,
dass ich Abstand brauchte.
Das hat uns beiden geholfen,
uns wieder besser zu finden.
Also jeder sich selbst, dadurch
konnte man sich wieder annähern.
Wie war es denn umgekehrt für dich,
als du erfahren hast,
dass Katharina
eine andere Beziehung hatte?
Mein Selbstmitleid
war wahnsinnig gross.
Und ich gab mir voll die Kante -
auf allen Ebenen.
Bis ich quasi kollabierte -
physisch und psychisch.
Der Doktor meinte:
"Das ist nicht gut."
Wirklich. Ich war damals Mitte 20
und es hat mich ...
Ich hätte auch sterben können.
Das zu akzeptieren
war sehr schwierig für mich.
Es brauchte die andere Seite,
die offen dafür war,
mit mir darüber zu sprechen
und zu diskutieren.
Die Auseinandersetzung
dauerte ziemlich lange.
Das hat sich hingezogen.
Viele trennen sich
in einem solchen Moment - ihr nicht.
(Beide) Ja.
- Weshalb nicht?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Man kann
sagen, es ist fast schon ein Wunder.
Wenn man bedenkt,
was man sich alles zugemutet hat:
Verletzung, Trauer, Wut.
Ich erinnere mich an nächtliche
Diskussionen, Schlafentzug.
zermürbende Gespräche,
hin und her wälzen.
Das kann man vielleicht
im Alter von 30 noch,
aber später mit Kindern
wird das alles viel schwieriger.
Das hat uns sicher geholfen,
dass wir uns nicht getrennt haben:
dass wir uns auf die
Auseinandersetzung und Diskussionen
eingelassen haben.
Und dass wir
immer wieder bemerkt haben:
Wir wollen das eigentlich
nicht zerstören.
Das hat immer wieder Kraft gegeben.
Auf dem Weg hierher sagte ich,
dass ich ein Paar treffe,
das all diese Verletzungen erlebt
und die Krisen überstanden hat.
Nach 30 Jahren
sind sie noch immer zusammen.
Ist das Liebe oder Bequemlichkeit?
Nach diesem Treffen glaube ich aber,
lange zusammen zu sein
ist das Gegenteil
von Bequemlichkeit. Stimmt das?
Schön, dass du das sagst!
- Endlich merkt es jemand.
Es ist wirklich ein gutes Votum,
ich glaube das wirklich auch.
Man könnte es
schon fast bequem nennen -
es hat auch etwas Komfortables.
Aber eben nicht nur, es ist beides.
Es ist schon megacool, dass man sich
einfach darauf abstützen kann.
Nicht nur ein Gefühl von:
"Kann man das wirklich?"
Sondern ja,
man kann sich wirklich abstützen.
Und das, obwohl es Arbeit ist.
Ihr als Paar im mittleren
Lebensalter, drei Kinder,
beide beruflich extrem engagiert -
welche Themen beschäftigen euch?
Wie wir es schaffen,
in diesem dichten Alltag
schöne und auch entspannte Momente
gemeinsam zu kreieren.
Das ist sicher
eine der Herausforderungen.
Natürlich haben wir auch
eine extreme Effizienz entwickelt,
wie wir uns in kürzerer Zeit
näherkommen können.
* Mona lacht. *
Wir sind dem gegenüber
auch toleranter.
Was heisst das?
Wie kann ich deine Augen
interpretieren?
"Man muss nicht mehr
einen halben Tag kuscheln,
bevor man
miteinander ins Bett kann?"
(Beide) Genau!
* Lachen *
Und dass man 30 Min. gut gestalten
kann, wenn man es ernst nimmt.
Gewisse Paare
trennen sich einer Krise,
andere entscheiden sich
für ein neues Beziehungsmodell,
für eine polyamouröse Beziehung -
mit mehreren Menschen.
Wäre das für euch denkbar?
Grundsätzlich
gibt es viele verschiedene Formen.
Wenn es diese Form braucht,
kann ich mir das vorstellen.
Aber in unserer Beziehung,
so wie der Zustand jetzt ist,
kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen,
ich denke nicht daran.
Weil ihr euch genügt.
Kann man das so sagen?
Genügend gut, ja. Das ist sicher
ein wesentliches Wort.
Good enough, oder?
Ohne dieses ...
Das klingt jetzt so ... komisch.
Aber in der heutigen Welt
geht es immer darum:
"Ich will noch mehr, ich will jenes,
ich will 700 Joghurt
in der Migros kaufen können."
Es ist so ...
Man will alle möglichen Optionen.
Das good enough ist schon fast
unspektakulär, uncool.
Für mich hat das good enough
einen extremen Wert.
Ja, es ist good enough.
Das ist das Beste,
was man dazu sagen kann.
* Sanfte Soul-Musik *
Beim Sensual Speeddating
für Polyamore
kommt man sich unterdessen
tanzend näher.
Schau, was die Musik mit dir macht!
Die meisten hier sind monogam
in ihr Beziehungsleben gestartet.
Sie kennen die Tücken
einer Zweierbeziehung:
die Abnutzung, die Routine.
Es passieren Seitensprünge,
und das nicht zu knapp.
Die Partnerschaft öffnen und mehrere
Verbindungen gleichzeitig eingehen -
macht dieses Beziehungsmodell
glücklicher?
Mein Fazit ist,
dass die meisten Menschen
schlicht und einfach
nicht die Beziehungskompetenz haben
oder bereits
in ihrer Kernbeziehung beweisen,
um wirklich eine Öffnung zu machen.
Denn es braucht
noch mehr Kommunikation,
noch mehr Investition
und Abstimmung.
Es braucht auch - das mag jetzt
etwas romantisch klingen -
es braucht noch mehr Liebe
im Sinne einer Grosszügigkeit,
dass man vergeben kann,
dass man etwas aushalten kann,
auch schwierige Momente.
Diejenigen, die aus den
Kernbeziehungen fliehen wollen,
beweisen das oft
bereits dort zu wenig.
Genau. Dann kannst du die Augen
unter der Binde geschlossen lassen
und die Binde einfach über den Kopf
ziehen. Wir sammeln sie ein.
Du darfst sie ausziehen
und uns entgegenstrecken.
Deine Augen langsam wieder ans Licht
gewöhnen mit geschlossenen Lidern.
Dann darfst du jetzt
deine Augen wieder öffnen.
Wie tief kannst du dich
auf diese Begegnung einlassen?
Es ist die letzte Runde.
Nun dürfen sich die Frauen und Männer
zum ersten Mal in die Augen schauen.
Auch Monica ist offen
für neue Bekanntschaften.
Die dreifache Mutter ist seit
gut 20 Jahren polyamor unterwegs.
Sie nimmt gemeinsam mit Ehemann Chris
an diesem Anlass teil.
Wie die beiden lieben, das sehen wir
gleich im Anschluss des Datings.
* Heller Gongschlag *
Das war die letzte Begegnung von
heute Abend. Ihr habt's geschafft.
Mit wem hat es tatsächlich gepasst?
Die genaue Auswertung
wird per Mail nachgeliefert.
* Gläserne Klänge *
Ich bin teilweise total überrascht,
wie tief das gehen kann.
Obwohl man das kennt -
Berührungen und den Austausch.
Aber dass es so tief geht,
hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich bin verwirrt ... total verwirrt.
Aber auf eine
positive Art und Weise.
Ich habe es
als erfrischend empfunden,
in diese reine Sinnlichkeit
zu gehen.
Und ich habe eine grosse Dankbarkeit
euch gegenüber,
dass ihr diesen Raum
geschaffen habt.
Ich bin auf dem Weg
zu Monica und Chris,
die beiden haben wir beim
Speeddating kennengelernt.
Sie haben sich entschieden,
dass sie polyamourös leben wollen.
Ich bin gespannt, was das für sie
als Familie bedeutet -
v.a. für ihre drei Kinder.
* Türklingel und Kinderstimmen
im Hintergrund *
Hallo!
- Chris, ich freue mich sehr.
Hoi, Mona.
- Monica, freut mich!
Das sind die Kinder?
Mona, freut mich. Hallo zusammen.
Darf ich einfach hineinkommen?
- Auf jeden Fall.
* Unverständliche Stimmen *
Monica und Chris,
Technische Redaktorin und Geschäfts-
führer eines IT-Unternehmens.
Als Teenager verliebt,
später geheiratet, drei Kinder,
mittlerweile seit 31 Jahren ein Paar.
Die erste Frage, die mir
gestellt wurde, als ich sagte,
ich lerne ein Paar kennen,
das polyamourös lebt:
"Wie viele haben sie denn nebenbei?"
Starten wir also gleich
voll ins Thema. - Voll!
Ich habe zwei weitere Beziehungen.
Eine seit ungefähr zehn Jahren,
mal mehr, mal weniger intensiv.
Und seit drei Monaten bin ich
über beide Ohren frisch verliebt.
Das ist mein aktueller Stand.
Ich habe drei Freundinnen.
Eine, die etwas weiter weg wohnt -
300 km entfernt.
Mit ihr bin ich
seit zweieinhalb Jahren zusammen.
Dann habe ich zwei
etwas neuere Beziehungen
zu Frauen aus der Zentralschweiz.
Da kommt also einiges zusammen.
Wie hat es denn begonnen?
Ihr kennt euch seit Teenagerjahren.
Ja, mit 18
haben wir uns kennengelernt
und waren gegenseitig
die ersten Partner.
Zu Beginn war es natürlich
gar kein Thema.
Aber nach vier, fünf Jahren
haben wir beide gemerkt,
dass es noch
so viele interessante Leute gibt.
Wir haben Lust
auf fremde Haut bekommen.
Aber wir wollten zusammenbleiben.
Wir haben uns überlegt,
welche Möglichkeiten es gibt.
Wir liebten uns,
wir mochten uns sehr.
Uns zu trennen,
um andere Erfahrungen zu sammeln,
wäre völlig schräg gewesen
und hätte nicht gestimmt.
Dann kamen wir auf die Idee,
miteinander fremdzugehen.
Zu Beginn
war es wirklich körperlich.
Es ging darum,
fremde Haut zu spüren.
Aber mit der Zeit
hat sich das stark verändert.
Wir haben bemerkt, dass es für uns -
für andere mag das anders sein -
zu wenig ist.
Es war vielleicht auch
zu oberflächlich.
In dieser Zeit haben wir oft
miteinander darüber gesprochen:
"Was passiert jetzt mit mir?"
Ich empfinde jetzt etwas anderes
als zuvor,
als es nur um das Körperliche ging.
Dann mussten wir uns wieder einigen,
ob das eigentlich stimmt.
Damals wussten wir noch nicht,
dass es einen Begriff
wie Polyamorie gibt.
Das ist ja schon eine weile her.
Wie habt ihr es denn definiert?
Es war einfach unser Weg.
Wir haben es gar nicht
als irgendetwas definiert.
Erst viel später
haben wir den Begriff kennengelernt.
Noch später,
erst vor ein paar Jahren, sahen wir,
dass es andere gibt, die auch
so leben. - Quasi eine Community.
Und wir dachten:
"Was, es gibt noch andere Freaks?"
Ihr habt euch als Freaks gesehen?
- Schon ein wenig.
Weil die Gesellschaft das nicht ...
Man spricht nicht darüber.
Es ist kein übliches Konzept,
um es so zu sagen.
Die übliche Konzepte
sind Monogamie oder das Fremdgehen.
Das wird toleriert,
darüber spricht man, das weiss man.
Aber diese Form
kennt man bisher noch nicht.
Könnt ihr sagen:
"Bis dorthin und nicht weiter?"
Wo sind eure Grenzen?
Was ganz klar nicht geht,
ist Geschlechtsverkehr mit
einer anderen Person ohne Kondom.
Das geht gar nicht.
Das ist eine ganz klare Grenze.
Eine Weile war auch die Frage:
Was passiert hier zu Hause,
wenn jemand hierherkommt
und ich nicht da bin?
Ist z.B. das Ehebett mit einem
anderen Partner ein Tabubereich?
Ist es das?
Nicht mehr so, also ...
Es war auch schon so, als wir ...
Bei solchen Dingen denkt man
im Voraus, es sei in Ordnung.
Dann merkt man aber doch ...
- Es ist doch etwas komisch.
Zu Beginn sagte ich auch,
das sei gar kein Thema.
Das ist einfach und ...
Dann merkte ich ...
Nein, es fühlt sich
irgendwie nicht richtig an.
Ein weiteres Thema ist,
mit jemandem in der Öffentlichkeit
Hand in Hand zu gehen.
Ausserhalb unserer Beziehung.
Wie macht man das?
Was, wenn uns jemand sieht?
Darüber muss man sprechen.
Macht man das auch?
Ja. - Bis vor einem Jahr
hielten wir es geheim.
Bis dahin haben wir das nicht
gemacht, ausser man war weiter weg.
Wenn ich in München oder Hamburg
war, war das kein Thema.
Aber wir haben ganz klar gesagt,
dass das in Luzern oder Emmenbrücke
nicht infrage kommt.
Ja, das hatte auch stark
mit den Kindern zu tun.
Wir haben ja drei Kinder.
Ich wollte auf keinen Fall,
dass das Eltern
von Schulfreunden sehen
und irgendwelche Gerüchte
in die Welt setzen
und das quasi auf der Kinderebene
ausgetragen wird.
"Deine Mutter geht fremd", oder so.
- Genau.
Dann weiss sie: "Oh nein,
das habe ich schon gehört."
"Dann trennen sich die Eltern."
Dann entsteht eine Aufregung um
etwas, was bei uns kein Thema ist.
Das war der Grund, weshalb wir
fast 25 Jahre lang nichts sagten.
Wir wollten, dass die Kinder
ein stabiles Umfeld haben
und nicht Einflüsse von aussen
hineininterpretiert werden,
die gar nicht existieren.
Meistens möchte man als Teenager
gar nicht wissen,
dass die Eltern überhaupt
ein Sexualleben haben.
Wie war das bei dir,
als sie euch das gesagt haben?
Ich finde es nicht schlimm,
zu wissen, dass sie miteinander
oder mit anderen Partnern schlafen.
Das ist voll okay.
- Kennst du die anderen Partner?
Ich glaube,
ich habe schon welche kennengelernt,
aber dachte, es seien nur Kollegen.
Aber die jetzigen glaube ich nicht,
oder zumindest nicht bewusst.
(Monica) Für die Kinder
sind es einfach unsere Kollegen.
Die waren auch hier,
wir hatten schöne Abende,
gemeinsam gegessen,
etwas unternommen,
aber es waren einfach Kollegen.
Soll ich das wegen London sagen?
- Ja.
Ja. Also, eines, das wir ...
Wir machen zusammen
mit einer Freundin eine Städtereise.
Die Tochter der Freundin
und Thia kommen auch mit.
Das haben wir so noch nie gemacht.
Das wird ein spannendes Experiment,
um es so zu sagen.
Möchtest du seine Partnerinnen
kennen und umgekehrt?
Unbedingt!
- Weshalb?
Ich kenne sie auch alle.
Das ist für mich extrem wichtig.
Ich möchte wissen,
welche Person ihm wichtig ist.
Kaum vorstellbar.
Gab es nie Streit, Eifersucht?
Eifersucht nicht, nein.
- Nein.
Aber es brauchte ein Angleichen.
Einen weiteren Partner zu haben,
ist auch eine Zeitfrage.
Wie manage ich meine Zeit?
Wo bin ich öfter?
Das ist schwierig.
Aber es gab auch viele Diskussionen
auf der Gefühlsebene.
Und es gab auch Tränen, definitiv.
Das war wirklich ein Prozess.
Einmal musste der eine ein wenig
zurückstecken, dann der andere.
Aber wir waren immer in einem
guten Gespräch. Das ist wertvoll.
Ist Monogamie
etwas Unnatürliches für Menschen?
Ich persönlich bin davon überzeugt,
dass der Mensch
von Natur aus nicht monogam ist.
D.h. aber nicht,
dass man nicht monogam leben kann.
Ein Paar, das 50 Jahre lang monogam
lebt und dabei glücklich ist -
davor habe ich grössten Respekt,
super, toll.
Diese zwei müssen eine Form finden,
in der sie gemeinsam glücklich sind.
Aber wenn ich von Statistiken höre,
dass 70 % der Menschen mit dem
Gedanken spielen, fremdzugehen,
und 50 % schon einmal
fremdgegangen sind -
und das heimlich, dann haben sie
deswegen ein schlechtes Gewissen -,
dann ist für mich
unsere Beziehungsform viel ...
... wirklich viel besser.
Das geht ins Thema Mitfreude.
Dass ich mich darüber freue, wenn es
ihr gut geht - oder umgekehrt.
Wenn sie frisch verliebt ist
wie jetzt.
Ja, genau.
- Ich erinnere mich, als ...
... als sie zum ersten Mal
mehrere Tage bei ihm war.
Als sie zurückkam, habe ich sie
am Flughafen Kloten abgeholt.
Sie kam um die Ecke
und hat gestrahlt -
der ganze Raum war golden
erleuchtet, als sie um die Ecke kam.
Da habe ich mich
sehr für sie gefreut.
Aber ich denke ...
- Was ...
Ich kann einfach ich selbst sein.
Das geniesse ich,
es fühlt sich gut an.
Die Liebe zwischen uns beiden
ist da, und sie ist sehr stark.
Den Mut zu haben,
das Leben so zu leben,
wie es für einen selbst stimmt,
damit man sich später
nicht vorwerfen muss,
man habe das Wesentliche verpasst -
das führt uns zur nächsten Sendung
"Reporter spezial": Leben im Alter.
Ist es eine Idee,
dass wir unsere Pflegebedürftigen
ins Ausland exportieren -
z.B. nach Ungarn?
Das klären wir in der nächsten
Sendung am nächsten Sonntag.